I'm Rob Anderson and this is Al Jazeera
live from dohab also coming up Ukraine
launches its largest drone strikes in
Russian territories since the War Began
hitting six regions millions in Florida
are braced for impact hurricane idalia's
to hit as a category 4 storm in the next
few hours
Sudan's military leader promises free
and fair elections as Egypt's President
offers mediation for peace
[Music]
we're going to start with breaking news
out of Gabon senior members of the
military have appeared on television
saying they're now in control of the
oil-rich Central African country they've
ordered all institutions to be dissolved
military leaders have also announced the
cancellation of Saturday's election
result the Electoral commission says
president alibongo won a third term in
office he said to have got nearly 65
percent of the vote
foreign
[Music]
irresponsible after noting an
irresponsible unpredictable governance
which results in a continuous
deterioration of social cohesion that
risks leading the country to chaos today
the 30th of August 2023 in the name of
the gabonese people we the committee of
the transition and the restoration of
Institutions have decided to defend the
peace putting an end to the regime in
place
to this end the general elections of
August 26 2023 as well as the results
are canceled
the borders of the country are closed
until further notice
all the institutions of the Republic are
dissolved the government the Senate the
National Assembly the Constitutional
Court we call on the population for calm
and serenity and we affirm our
attachments to the respect of gabon's
commitments to the International
Community okay for more than this we're
going to bring in Catherine soy she's
following developments from Nairobi in
Kenya what more do we know about what's
going on Catherine
released on gabanti this is a state Iran
TV station that is
yeah unfortunately we've got a few
problems getting hold of Catherine there
we will of course try and get her back
later in the program as this is a
breaking story she'll have a lot more
information but in the moment at the
moment we're going to go to Tara
O'Connor she's the founder and executive
director of Africa risk Consulting she's
joining us from the city of Bordeaux in
France very good to have you with us on
Al Jazeera why do you think that this
has happened now just a few days after
the election result
well it seems that this is a
continuation of control of one family uh
The Bongo family you know Ali Ben Bongo
the president who actually won the
elections uh took over from his father
14 years ago so I think there is a deep
resentment in West Africa on around
dynastic style politics
but nevertheless
um this military intervention should
really be seen in the context of perhaps
the military interventions uh in
neighboring francophone countries Mali
Burkina Faso and most recently Niger
the the military are saying that they're
ordering the dissolution of government
Senate National Assembly and
constitutional court is there any
indication that they're a in a position
to order that and B will people actually
listen
well I think it's as we've seen
elsewhere the you know when a military
takes over it's at the barrel of a gun
so people do tend to be a bit cautious
um but the definitely the boat uh the
Omar Bongo um descendants um Ali Ben
Bongo they were particularly unpopular
there was a lot of a challenge to the
elections and the elections took place
under curfew with uh limited media and
so on so
um so really even extending the uh Ali
Ben Bongos extending his term to a third
term was particularly popularly
unpopular well it was unpopular with
people it's already or has there been
any indication in gabon's past that this
kind of thing Could Happen does it have
a history of this kind of military
intervention
yes it does there was an attempt against
uh there was an attempted coup against
um Ali Ben bongo's father Omar Bongo but
that was actually put down by French
intervention
um but France has long since changed its
policy towards its former colonies and
gaboy is one of the key former very
loyal former colonies to France and but
France has particularly changed that
since Emmanuel macron came into power
and has sought to widen France's
relationships to Nigeria to South Africa
to Kenya and reduce its dependence and
reduce these very strong tied links to
the former Frank set the Frank Zone
countries as they're called is there any
indication do you think that France is
going to be put in a position where it
feels it has to get involved in this or
is it going to be taking up fairly
hands-off approach to what's happening
in Gabon
I think it will be a hands-off approach
this is very much a a big problem for
France and another coup in francophone
what is traditionally called in France
the francophone West African countries
will be very unpopular in France
um but from you know
um I doubt very much that macron will
respond within with an intervention as
has happened in the past unless Francis
called upon to do so by ecowas or the
African Union or the regional bodies
that are that have been taking a very
prominent role in uh in other military
coups in the region such as most
recently in Niger where the Icarus and
the 15-member regional body has actually
announced that it has got preparations
for a military intervention in Niger to
restore the Constitutional order and we
will watch to see what those Regional
bodies and what the African union says
now about this latest in this string of
coups
I want to ask you about a government's
economy it's an OPEC member it's a an
oil producing country fifth largest oil
producing nation in Africa I understand
but it also has Diversified into other
areas as well there are clearly going to
be fought and interests who have uh
investments in that how concerning is
this going to be for those for those
foreign investors and of course for
foreign governments as well
it's
concerning for foreign investors
um obviously because the suspension of
the of the rule of law in military
intervention is effectively a suspension
of the rule of law and uh and Gabon yes
you're right you're right to say it's a
produces about uh I think it's
production current production is around
000 barrels of oil so it's not a huge
producer in sort of in terms of its OPEC
membership but what's much more
important is gabon's role in the new
energy transition it is a major producer
of Manganese it's a major producer of of
minerals uranium that are very important
for the future energy transition so
geopolitically it's important but also
very important much more so to to France
to European relations and then say the
OPEC countries let me ask you about the
more local relations in borders the
Republic of Congo and Equatorial Guinea
what do you think the impact is going to
be there how are they going to be seeing
this
well in gab
well Congo is very much more a as
authoritarian State as is Equatorial
Guinea so I don't think the I don't
think the rash of coups will worry those
two regimes particularly as they are
quite tightly controlled by their
leaders but the country that I would be
more concerned about would be Senegal
where you know you have a very unpopular
president who is all equally trying to
manipulate uh fourth upcoming elections
by all sorts of means including uh you
know arresting and imprisoning
opposition leaders
O'Connor founder and executive director
of Africa risk Consulting we appreciate
it very much indeed thank you very much
thank you
now I can go back to Catherine soy who
we were talking to earlier about the
latest from what was happening in Gabon
Catherine thanks very much indeed for
coming back to us I know we had a few
phone problems what do we know then
about the situation in Gabon at the
moment
yes so um this statement was released on
Gabon TV it's a state-run TV station
that is based within uh the presidency
and those who addressed that uh briefing
uh were members of the army uh there
will be so a presidential guards as well
and they're calling themselves the
committee for to the transition and
restitution of the institutions and they
say that they don't believe that the
election was free uh or fair or
transparent and they say that they are
very frustrated uh because
um the government has not been following
the will of the people so people have
been told uh to stay at home until the
situation is resolved and we've been
talking to some people in Gabon who have
been following these development and we
are saying that that's been telling me
uh that uh during the campaigns uh
during the voting as well uh people were
not very confident that the election uh
will be uh free free and fair because of
different uh changes that were that
happened uh when it comes to the
election for example
um
election observers International
election observers were bird from
um you know for not deployed the
government says that there will not be
accredited uh this case happens with um
also International journalists as well
we are tried to get accredited uh but it
was not possible so people are saying
that this uh a recipe for this and what
is happening uh now and we have also
been told that the position had already
said that they will not accept the
results the results were announced very
very early this morning and this is what
uh precipitated all this and um the you
know the people uh and these officials
who addressed this Co say they want to
make things right so we don't know where
the president is right now uh he he
should be liberal the car the capital
city but we don't know exactly where he
is
um those who addressed the press
conference did not mention uh whether
they have him or where exactly he is but
we also know uh that the opposition
leader uh
um Mr also uh the the opposition leader
we know that he is not in the country he
left the country immediately after
voting because he said that his life was
in danger we don't know which country he
is in right now so the situation is
still very fluid and people are staying
home
Catherine thank you very much indeed
obviously we're still in the early hours
of what's happening in Gabon but I know
we're going to be checking in with you
as time goes on thank you very much
indeed Catherine soy
thank you